Today on Journey to the Microcosmos, we're
going to be doing something a little bit different.
See, here at Microcosmos headquarters we've
been putting in a lot of nights and weekends
to make sure you have an upload every Monday,
or occasionally Tuesday.
And while somedays are for learning, other
days might be better spent just looking.
And thus, so we can get a little bit ahead
and maybe be a little less stressed, and also
so you can, if you want, just chill with some
of our favorite tiny beasts, today's episode
is going to be just music and video.
Basically, here are some really cool little
organisms, and I'm just going to go.
Bye!
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us, as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
As always, if you want see more from our Master
of Microscopes, James, check out Jam and Germs
on instagram.
And we will be back with more regularly scheduled
programming next week.